[Music]
in today's Information Age everyone sort
of thinks they've seen and heard it all
yeah we're pretty jaded like nothing new
nothing new nothing could surprise him
we did some research and we discovered
that there are actually several phrases
left that no human being has ever said
out loud even in this day of the
internet and Twitter and everything
phrases no one's ever said until tonight
brace yourself ladies and gentlemen
because it's time for things that have
never ever been said the following
sentences have never ever been uttered
before in human history please give a
big Apollo Theater welcome to Michael
Buble
[Music]
i watch Dateline last night and the
murderer was not the husband please I
can only be helped by so many Home Depot
employees at once could you pass along
your quinoa recipe I work hard but not
Kardashian hard
[Music]
my sentiments exactly gary busey hello
my breasts are down here
[Music]
let's lift weights to some James Taylor
music we met on tinder and now we're
engaged did you remember to invite
Clarence Thomas whoa check out the new
lunch lady hey when is Bruce will is
going to record another album
I'm a tax accountant so it's just day
after day of free oral sex best place to
get sneakers CVS I enjoyed the movie but
I couldn't figure out which character
was played by Tyler Perry
[Music]
more diarrhea please oh my god Conan
it's giant
[Applause]
not they're good